[Music]
this is the weapons test up first the
kill test doug
to see what kind of lethal damage your
halberd will do
we'll take your hull bird and deliver
thrust hacks and attempt to dismount
that dummy with its hook
fill your purse you ready for this yes
sir
well phil i would love to test your
blade but i'm still recovering from an
injury so to help me horse around with
your weapon today please welcome my
brother rj marketa
let's do this i spent a long time making
that thing and i want to see it work
[Music]
all right phil your spear tip is sharp
not only at the point but its edges also
your accent not only did it dig in and
break the ribs it went in and cut the
internal organs that were behind the
ribs and the hook blade it dug into the
ribs and dismounted the dummy from the
horse overall your weapon here will kill
thank you good job all right jonathan
you're up next you ready let's do it my
halberd's a brute i'm excited to hear
doug tell me it'll kill that'll make my
son happy i want to see some blood and
gordon guts
[Music]
all right jonathan on the thrust your
spear tip right here penetrated deep and
created a deep wound channel
your accent here
pretty much it was just the tip that
penetrated into the chest and also into
the diaphragm your hook broke the ribs
got into the organs and dismounted the
whole dummy from the horse
the most important thing about this
whole thing is
it will kill
all right bladesmiths next up is a
strength test
[Music]
to test the strength and durability of
your hull birds i'll be chopping into
this corrugated sheet steel remember
this test is all about what the steel
does to your hubbards and not what your
alberts do to this deal fill you up
first you ready yes sir
well phil your hubbard held up perfectly
all of the faces on it are still razor
sharp there's no deformation that i can
see
overall very well done thank you
jonathan you're up you ready get some
[Music]
well jonathan on the hits your edges
held up pretty well i don't see any
problems with them the one thing that
does concern me is the blade's taking a
bit of a bend to one side here but the
edges and the points seem to have done
pretty well in the penetration the whole
thing held up still solid well done
up next is the sharpness test and for
that i give you to dave
all right bladesmiths to test the
sharpness of your blades i'll be cutting
through these fish using both the blade
and the tip of your
now a sharp blade should cut through
those fish nice and clean
phil you ready go for it
the slicing test is the scariest one for
me because the edges on my hall bird are
thick i don't know how well they'll do
cutting something fairly soft
[Music]
all right
the cuts look very clean they're just
nice slices
i really like the design of this weapon
the handle feels good it's got some heft
to it but it's balanced nicely but most
off it's definitely a sharp weapon we
built the cutter good job thank you sir
jonathan you ready always
phil's blade performed pretty good in
the fish test i didn't know we're gonna
cut fish with it i'm sweating at
geometry
all right jonathan you went with
actually trying to forge this all out of
one piece which i appreciate it's just
there's still a lot of that weight here
the socket's very very thick it's
covered but you can feel the edge of it
the shape you see that historically
quite a bit but for this test it's a
little harder to find the sweet spot on
that shape with that tip being knocked
out of alignment a little bit harder to
target harder to index but it's a good
cutter nicely done
phil jonathan you've both done some
amazing work on your german halberds and
they perform very well in our weapons
tests however in this arena of
competition only the best weapon can win
and our next forest and fire champion is
phil
congratulations you are a new fortune
fire champion jonathan unfortunately
your weapon did not make the cut ben
abbott's going to tell you why
jonathan at the end of the day your
halberd was heavy more difficult to
wield and took a bend in the strength
test and for those reasons we have to
let you go
jonathan please surrender your weapon
i feel honored to have competed with
phil and the other two guys in this
competition had a good time if you do
compete in this
be ready have your skills on point
because you will be tested
phil congratulations you are our new
forged and fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a check for ten
thousand dollars good job it's all the
hard work worth it the hard work was
worth it i'm very pleased to have been
here it was wonderful well phil
please present your weapon to the judges
with pleasure
philip baldwin won and phil baldwin
feels very good about winning
i would not have missed the experience
of appearing on fortune fire for
anything in the world i met some really
fine people i would have never met in
any other circumstances
and i really thank my fellow competitors
for being here
[Music]
mike alex welcome back to the forge
you've had five days at your home for
just to work on your horseman's axes
mike tell us about your weapon
it's a little rougher on the edges but i
think it will perform well
and i can't wait to see it happen
alex
everything just fell into place for me
even though i had to make some last
minute changes and i'm looking forward
to seeing it tear apart some ballistics
dummies
all right gentlemen up first
the kill test doug
the horseman's axe is actually two
weapons in one it's got an edge that can
lacerate in chop and a spike that can
penetrate and crush bones to see what
kind of lethal damage your axe will do
i will take your horseman sacks and
deliver lethal blows on this ballistics
dummy
mike you're up first you ready yes i am
as you can see i'm recovering from an
injury so one of my students will have
the satisfaction of testing your weapon
well mike let's talk about your weapon
your edge over here is sharp it
lacerated deep into the bowels right
here your spike definitely caved in all
the way into the chest and straight into
the heart the only issue we have is that
your handle is a little bit on the
rounded side so there is a tendency to
slightly roll but overall your weapon
will kill thank you
alex you're up next you ready yes let's
do this all right
i'm pretty proud of what i created it's
just a little heavy and that's a bit of
a concern going in
sweet
alex your weapon here is a little bit on
the heavy side
but you know what it is well balanced
the edge of your blade here cut deep in
the chest cavity and it broke the bones
your spike here right into the heart and
of course on the swing it pretty much
just disemboweled the dummy right there
your weapon
will kill yes thank you
next up is the strength test jake
now we know ice can be very brutal on an
edge so i'm going to take your
horseman's axes and repeatedly strike
into these large blocks of ice to see
where they hold up mike you're up first
you ready yes i am
i think alex has the advantage at this
time so going into the ice block test
i'm concerned
there may be a fail point in the head
handle area
but this is it i'm very nervous
oh mike unfortunately we had a serious
failure on your axe
with a swelled point in the junction of
the belt hook
alex
you still have to pass this test are you
ready yes i'm ready
there's only one thing standing between
me and a thousand dollar check
and it's really big and it's made of ice
[Music]
[Music]
uh alex your horseman's axe did quite a
job on that ice
everything's still tight
your edge is still razor sharp thank you
so all in all very nicely done
bladesmiths our weapons tests here are
designed to be exceptionally brutal in
order to set your weapons apart from one
another
mike
your blade did not survive our strength
test for that reason i have to ask you
to please leave the forge okay
i am disappointed but when i go home i'm
gonna have a smile on my face
forged and fired has risen me from the
dead somehow
i will take this forward with me for the
rest of my life
alex congratulations you are the forest
and fire champion and will be receiving
a check for ten thousand dollars good
job
[Applause]
it's surreal it's really surreal well
come on over here and shake our hands oh
wow
i can't really fathom like i won like i
i won definitely tops everything else
i've ever done
being the fortune fire champion just
shows i've applied what i've always
tried to teach others
never stop learning
to see what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do i'll take your glaze on
deliver thrust and slashes on this deer
carcass nick you're up first you ready
guess so let's do this
yeah i'm feeling pretty good i'm just
excited to see what's gonna happen i'm
hoping this is the only big dead animal
i have to deal with today
to be my arm today bladesmiths please
welcome back r.j marcaida
today he will wield your weapon
[Music]
[Music]
first up right here on your edge it
picked up a chip
on another side of this you can feel
where the edge also rolled
but this weapon is sharp on the initial
thrust it's got a geometry right there
that penetrated deep into the carcass
your edge right here on slashing it
lacerated easily on the side of this
deer carcass on the third cut the weight
of this weapon is so balanced it's easy
to lacerate all the way through your
weapon will kill
thank you
all right alex your turn
his seems to do really well it stabs
right through it slashes real nicely so
i'm excited to see what mine does and
like a little bit like throwy-uppy like
to right there
[Music]
all right alex your tip
is sharp enough to lacerate all the way
through on the slash of this edge it's
lacerated easily
on the side rib of this particular
carcass
on the wide swing
it did break half of the spine off it is
as you can see a little bit on the wider
side and the heavy weapon like this a
wide handle can make it hard to control
yeah but the most important thing
it will kill thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test the pike chop
that was intense i wasn't ready for that
often in pike warfare the glaives or
weapons like them are used as a
secondary line of defense to push the
pike up out of the way and or to chop at
the pike shaft so to test the strength
and durability of your weapons including
the hook on the back i'll be pushing
these pikes up into position then
chopping at them with the blades all
right neck you're up first you ready yes
sir
[Music]
i'd say that's pretty good
all right so nick it doesn't look like
your weapon took any more damage to the
edge the weight of your blade is very
nicely balanced a good design definitely
a strong blade nicely done thank you
alex you ready yes sir i'm in and out of
i think i got this to i have no idea
what's gonna happen so i still feel i
gotta get shot i think i'm still in the
running
kick ass
don't break it be nice
that was brutal dude
first off your blade did take some
damage here they're very small chips and
rolls
your flanges here are just wide enough
that when i pushed forward i managed to
grab two rows of pikes and push them
back at the same time balance is nice on
it the shaft is pretty wide it's not too
big but it's right on the outside edge
of what's comfortable for my hand but
everything held up everything solid
thank you because alex's blade picked a
couple of chips up we're really even
closer to even at this point all right
gentlemen now it's time for the
sharpness test to test the sharpness of
your blade i'll be cutting these ropes
now that releases the bag and i'll be
cutting the bag now unlike the strength
test this is all about what your weapons
do to these targets
nick you're up first you ready
this is obviously the final test that's
coming up it's gonna be the deciding
factor who wins i think we're still
running neck and neck so it's fun to
have a tight race
[Music]
that's pretty cool yeah
well nick cut through the bags really
cleanly and what i really like is the
balance of this weapon it's very easy to
maneuver it didn't have to fight the
weapon nicely done thank you all right
alex you're up you ready yes sir
i feel like we are pretty neck and neck
thus far if mine doesn't do well i think
it's pretty clear what's gonna happen
and if it does i'm just at a loss i have
no idea
[Music]
all right
your blade is wicked sharp
this passed right through the rope with
very little resistance at all and it cut
the bags beautifully the balance of your
blade is a little bit more to the tip so
the one thing about this blade when i
cut with it is slowing it down after the
cut but uh it's a beautiful cutter did a
great job thank you
nick alex you've both done an incredible
amount of work on your finale weapons
however there can only be one forest and
fire champion and that champion is
[Music]
nick
congratulations you are our next fortune
fire champion alex unfortunately your
weapon didn't make the cut david baker's
gonna tell you why
alex you both brought us beautiful
weapons both your weapons took damage
really came down to that large handle
and the forward weight and it's that
fine a point that's sending it home alex
please surrender your blade
so the final judgment i am not the
fortune fire champion it's definitely a
long road to get all the way here and it
is disappointing but nick won he
absolutely killed it he made a great
weapon i'm super happy for him it was a
tight race so it's been a fun experience
but it's it's back to work now
nick congratulations you are our new
forged and fire champion and that's the
title that comes with a check for 10
grand good
job thank you
nick please present your weapon to the
judges i'm forging the fire champion
that's so weird but awesome what can i
say i made the right choices with the
handle slimmed it down a little bit i
got to make some really cool stuff meet
some really cool people and being
champion that's just a really cool bonus
bladesmiths the arming sword it's a cut
and thrust weapon
to test the lethality of your arming
sword i will deliver slashes and thrust
on these bore carcasses
john you're up first you ready for this
yes sir let's do this
that hide is super thick to get through
that you really need a very fine edge
and not a lot of weight behind it and i
didn't build that
all right john let's talk about your
arming sword here it's heavy
it did cut on some parts of the carcass
other parts it just bounced off
thrusting wise though it did what it was
designed for
this will kill thank you sir
all right drew you're up you ready yes
sir let's do this
when i saw john's blade hit the carcass
first few times it didn't really cut so
great so i'm worried about my sharpness
on my blade
oh nice
[Music]
all right drew
this is a very sharp blade a great
thrusting blade and i like how you put a
counterbalance right here because all
the weight is nicely distributed so
where i can thrust and slash
your blade sir
will kill
thank you good job thank you
bladesmiths welcome to our strength test
one of my favorites the ice block chop
and we supersized it
what i'm gonna do is take each of your
swords i'm gonna beat them repeatedly
and viciously into this big chunk ice
it's gonna test the overall construction
of your sword as well as its edge
holding ability now what your swords do
to the ice is secondary compared to what
the ice does to your swords
and john you're up first how you feeling
buddy
nervous
well we're gonna do it anyway so yeah
hmm
ah
[Music]
well this is very heavy very hard to
control
also
aside from having gaps in your shoulders
here you've got a pretty good bend in
the blade and that was there before i
started
not a lot of edge left but you survived
through how you feeling
i'm ready good so am i
jay's tough on blades
ice is tough on blades it doesn't matter
who's swinging on it
and i'm just praying at this point that
nothing fails
[Music]
drew this is a beautiful sword thank you
blade is still
razor sharp which is very impressive
with an ice block chop
that being said the ice block chop is
meant to be brutal it's meant to test
the overall structure integrity of your
sword from tip to pommel
the problem is i'm holding your pummel
in his hand instead of this hand
so that's an issue yeah
drew
your blade has suffered a catastrophic
failure
i have to ask you to please leave the
forge
i'm sad that my blade failed but i feel
really good about the fact that i was
able to
make something completely outside of my
wheelhouse but none of that matters if
the bomb will comes flying off if the
functionality is in there the aesthetics
really do not matter i had a ton of fun
i would do it again in a second i'm
super excited to get back to the west
coast and just get back to work chipping
away at my custom orders
[Music]
john congratulations you're the next
forage and fire champion good job
like
you'll be receiving a check for 10 000
how do you feel i didn't want to win
like that but i feel pretty good
i made butter knives in the first round
i come back with a beast of an armament
sword and now i'm fortunate for our
champion good job brother when i get
home the first thing i'm doing is buying
a press and get right back out to the
shop and forward some more it is only
driving me to do it more
[Music]
bladesmiths this is the strength test in
history chainmail was used to defend
knights against blades and swords and
even today it protects divers from
sharks to test the strength and
durability of your daggers i am going to
be slashing and stabbing into this
chainmail once each with either side of
your blades remember it's not what
happens to the chainmail it's what
happens to your dagger that counts david
you're up you ready yes sir all right
uh i didn't really have a lot of time to
get the edge where i wanted to be
that could be a problem
[Music]
[Music]
well david the guard is sharp at the top
it did bite into my left hand as i'm
stabbing another two seconds on the
grinder would have fixed that
there's a little bit of edge deformation
from the chopping but your tip held up
perfectly i don't see any problems there
overall good work thank you
josh how you feeling pretty good all
right let's do this
[Music]
so
well josh not a huge fan of the
welding the cross guard on here
i mean it really puts a weak spot right
where you need the most strength there's
a little bit of edge deformation
but overall it stayed tight
nice job thanks a lot
brian you ready
absolutely
given the catastrophic failure that i
experienced
when ben picks up my dagger i am
terrified there could be steel flying
across the forge which would never be a
good thing
[Music]
well brian
the handle is big
there's a lot of brass here so the whole
thing is really heavy
there's a little bit of edge deformation
from the cut right up near the weld but
otherwise it stayed solid
nice job thank you i am relieved it did
what it was supposed to with the chain
mail and if there were a critical
failure i'd be wearing a piece of blade
in my chest
all right gentlemen attest the sharpness
of your edge i'll be slicing into these
fish once with each edge of your knife
brian you're up first you ready
absolutely okay
[Music]
so brian
the edge profile of your blade is pretty
stout it's sharp up here
but the section that went through the
chain mail
most of that edge is just slightly
rolled over
so it cuts but it doesn't cut the way i
would like it to cut
josh you're up next i'm ready let's do
it
[Music]
[Music]
okay josh
up here i can run my fingers
right along the side of this blade
your blade has a very wide convex edge
you can see with the fish
i dented it as a purely thrusting dagger
it's very effective
as a cutter not so much
all right dave it's your turn you ready
that's why i'm here okay
[Music]
all right dave
the first cut beautiful
on the backside of the blade i can feel
a bit of a rolled spot
but
it's a good cutter nicely done thank you
bladesmiths the judges have made a final
decision it's time for one of you to
leave the forge
the blade smith leaving the forge
is josh your blade did not make the cut
josh this was an extremely close
decision but in the end it came down to
the fact that in the sharpness test your
blade just wasn't sharp enough to cut
that's why we're letting you go uh yes i
understand
josh please surrender your
dagger i was definitely disappointed
that my blade you know sliced all the
way through the fish but no regrets i
had a fun time me and my father you know
we went through the same experience even
though i'm not going through i'm sure my
dad's gonna be extremely proud of me
jeff craig because your weapons are
warhammers we decided to leave the forge
and bring them to a location a little
bit more benefiting their medieval style
we are now going to put both of your
weapons through three different tests
first up the sharpness test dave
gentlemen
the warhammer was primarily a close
quarters weapon but it was devastating
to anything it went up against which
occasionally was a castle door
so i'm going to take several strikes
against this oak door to see how well
the pick on your weapon penetrates
craig
you ready i'm ready
i see the doors set up and i'm thinking
my warhammer is just going to demolish
this door i'm pretty confident in my
hammer
[Music]
well craig
this really felt great in my hands
it's got a nice balance to it your pick
i don't see any real distortion on it
the shape of your pick with that nice
drop hook to the end of it
really penetrated well and you could see
when i got it in that door how hard it
was to remove yeah
nicely done appreciate it beautifully
executed thank you
so jeff your turn you ready we'll smash
it
all right
so
we started losing pieces
i could tell that they're on there only
decoratively so i was able to continue
on good thing head's still right and
tight all right
the way your pick leans out towards the
front
gave a lot of penetration i was really
able to just blow parts out of this door
nicely designed well executed thanks
bladesmiths now it's time for the kill
test warhammers have been known to
deliver piercing blows into armor and
crush the person behind it i will
deliver strikes at this ballistic dummy
that's wearing armor then we can see how
much lethal damage your warhammer can
give craig you're up are you ready i'm
ready let's do it
craig
love the balance of this blade
no indentations
now let's see how much damage we put on
the dummy
no visible broken bones
but it definitely did pierce the skin
nice
this will definitely kill
nicely done sir thank you
jeff you're up next are you ready yes
sir
the kill test it's the most important
part to me i wanted to smash that piece
of plate steel break some ribs and ruin
some organs
[Music]
[Music]
well jeff looks like the other line jay
did break off
do you know what
this is still very sturdy
but let's see how much damage is done
internally
he's got some broken ribs right here
broken bones throughout it went all the
way through
and
even through armor you pierce the skin
and you cause some internal damage
jeff
your weapon will kill awesome good job
thank you
gentlemen this is the strength test
the warhammer was a favorite on the
medieval battlefield so i'm going to
take your warhammer and to test its
strength and durability i'm going to
take several blows against our stone
wall and see how much of this i can move
you know i'm feeling pretty nervous i
know what it's capable of i've worked
with it at home but still yet watching
somebody else do it it's nerve-wracking
for me
wow that that held up really well
and that's pretty much a hole i could
crawl through
that'll work perfect
so the handle what i do like is i could
swing it one-handed but with two hands i
could generate a heck of a lot of energy
beautiful job excellent excellent thank
you
jeff
you're up let's knock it down
[Music]
it's long and when i was swinging it was
way out in front of me as opposed to
being close and in control
shot some sparks off
right seen that all in all a good
performance
great
well gentlemen as you've given the
judges a lot to consider we'll see you
back at the forge
[Music]
craig
jeff you were given five days at your
home forge to fabricate warhammers and
they both performed very well in our
weapons tests
but there can only be one forged empire
champion
jay
craig that's a great piece your fit and
finish is outstanding and i love the
fact that you can see the differential
heat treat in the hammer head and beak
there is a slight delamination in one
corner of the hammer face that does
concern me a little bit
jeff there's a word that they call
functional art you have it right there
the beautiful design you have of that
hammer is amazing
my only concern was during the kill test
the longer came off could have been
better secured
gentlemen
it was not an easy decision both of your
weapons are superb
but there can only be one forged and
fire champion
[Music]
craig
you are the forged and fire champion
congratulations thank you
jeff
your weapon did not make the cut
jeff with pieces coming off of it the
fact that it can only really be used as
a two-handed weapon those things added
together started to become a problem
please surrender your warhammer
i respected the judge's decision if i
knew what i knew now i would have
changed some things
craig congratulations you were the
forged and fired champion
it was a fun challenge
craig you will also be receiving a check
for ten thousand dollars i'm just stoked
it's crazy
this experience it was a grueling
process you know i got to do something
that i really enjoyed and i'm really
passionate about i came here for my son
i mean it doesn't get any better than
that
this is the kill test a night's temper
sword an iconic weapon battle tested
throughout history to see what kind of
lethal damage your weapon will do will
take your sword and deliver killing
blows on this ballistic stomach
brian you're up first going into testing
i'm uh
wondering if i spent enough time on the
grind i know that the quench was good so
there will be blood i'm quite certain of
that i would love to test your blade but
as you can see i'm still recovering from
an injury so to be my arm today please
welcome rj marcaida my brother he will
have the pleasure of building your
weapons
your sword is a little bit on the
heavier side but because of the pummel
you have over here it actually balances
it out
there are areas that are sharp and there
are areas that are not as sharp on the
final blow that edge have proven to be
very sharp and actually would disembowel
this ballistic stummy your sword sir
will kill
all right david your turn you ready
let's do it let's do this brian's blade
had cut
it's slashed it's stabbed we got some
competition here today just can't wait
to see how mine goes
that is one of the sharpest swords i've
ever come across
it's wicked scary
the cuts last week almost in half
without a doubt your weapon will kill
awesome then
gentlemen to test the strength and
durability of your edges i'm going to
attack these fully armored knights but
this test is all about what the armor
does to your sword not what your sword
does to the armor brian you're up first
you ready absolutely
[Music]
oh looks good
well brian
your edge held up really well
it's a very
obtuse grind that lends itself to this
kind of test the handle was comfortable
it's a nice shape i was able to index
very well
it stayed straight in the tests and
didn't pick up any damage well done
thank you
david you're up next
[Music]
[Music]
well dave you have a much finer edge on
this sword
and it's picked up a little bit of
rolling there's some edge deflection
right here you can
hear it but all in all very good source
thank you sir so next up is the
sharpness test and for that i'll give
you to dave
all right gentlemen next up the swinging
sandbag slice i will cut this rope with
one edge of your blade releasing that
sandbag and then cutting that with the
other edge of your blade let's see if
they still have an edge
ryan you're up are you ready
i am more than a little bit nervous
because dave's weapon is clearly a
slicer and parts
of my blade were not as sharp
as others
first off there are sections of this
blade that just
don't have much of an edge that first
cut and just skated up the rope second
cut bit in went right through you can
see how there's a lot of tearing
at the edge of that bag as opposed to a
clean slice through it
i would have loved to have seen a little
bit more edge especially on that front
half
david you ready absolutely okay
[Music]
your sword sharp very sharp pass through
the rope no problem
pass through the bag no problem as far
as the design of your sword
would have loved to have seen a
counterbalance on this uh this would be
nice on a dagger it's very small for
this sword without that counterbalance
all that weight is so far forward but
it's a cutter it's definitely sharp
nicely done thank you
blade smith the judges have completed
their deliberation and they've made a
final decision
you've both put in a lot of work here
but there can only be one forged and
fire champion and that champion is
dave
you are the forged and fire champion
brian unfortunately your crusader sword
did not make the cut
brian i really applaud the fact that you
brought a lot of yourself to that sword
in the end it came down to your sword
just wasn't as sharp as your competitors
and that's why we've got to let you go
understood
brian please surrender your sword
david's sword cut better than mine
he outsmithed me that's the way it goes
man in the end there can be only one i
may make another knight's templar
crusader sword i've still got 2 thousand
year old oak bits at home
i still have holy water at home
anything can happen
david congratulations you are the
fortune fire champion and that's a title
that comes with a check for how much 10
grand that's right 10 000 good job
victory feels good in this competition
it showed me that i
can push myself a little harder and get
more done looking forward to getting
back home first thing i'm gonna do is
fix my bike and go for a ride
bladesmiths welcome back
for the types of tests that we wanted to
do with your weapons we had to change
locations from the forge to a location
that provides a little bit more
maneuverability
yeah now it's time to find out whether
or not they're works of art
or deadly weapons of war
while the crusader sword was quite
powerful and effective on foot in sword
sword combat there was a method of
delivery that made it even more
destructive
from horseback
[Music]
that rider is going to use your weapons
to attack that ballistics gel torso
that's wearing a great helm gorget and
tunic
before we put your swords through the
kill test we first want to see if they
cannot break when subjected to a blow
delivered from on top of a horse at full
gallop
okay
i suggest we get out of the way i'm very
nervous full gallop on horseback
that's a lot of power to put into a
sword dave you're up first are you ready
i ain't gonna get any right here
three
two one engage
nice hit
so seeing the rider go up against this
dummy with my sword and it did not break
on impact that is absolutely awesome
pete your sword's up next let's see some
blood
i feel great that my sword held up well
but it didn't cut through the cloth
armor
to assess the damage and perform the
kill test i'm gonna hand you over to
doug
okay dave
it's got some weight to it
a creative sword should feel a bit heavy
in the hand
slashing feels good
let's see if it'll cut
okay
oh
you can see it points like a spear
beautiful thrusting capability
it's a killer
i had a lot of anxiety but i did really
good
at this point i'm ecstatic pete
so i'm now testing for thrusting with
length it's got a lot of weight to it
let's see what's going to do on the kill
test let's see
it will kill
all right gentlemen that concludes the
kill test now we're gonna head back to
the forge where we are going to perform
the strength test
welcome back
looks like your blades are standing up
to our tests
but we have one left we have the
strength test
okay
now i'm gonna turn you over to dave
who's an expert in european sword design
and usage
so we're done with the kill test at the
arena we're neck and neck on performance
gentlemen
a sword in combat went through extreme
stresses
so to test this i'm gonna take five
blows against these femurs see how far
through we can get with each of your
weapons
okay
pete you ready i'm ready all right
as soon as i see that they're going to
be chopping cow bones
that makes me really nervous
[Music]
[Music]
and while i was chopping this this
ring up here pretty rough on the hand
i'm just happy that my sword is still in
one piece at the end of this
got about halfway through that bone
just blowing pieces off of it
and still has an edge good
nice job thank you
dave you're up next you ready
sure
i'm seeing these femur bones i'm getting
ready to almost throw up i don't want to
see this destroyed
[Music]
[Music]
bench
a lot of stress in that blade
i'm kidding you can see the edge folded
over yeah
sort of bent right around that point of
impact right there
you can see we
chopped right through this bone
about three blows to crack that open
watching dave
work on those bones with my sword is the
absolute most nerve-wracking
stomach
twisting experience that i've ever had
as a knife maker
well done
until the judges say one way or the
other i'm still
i'm still nervous
you've both been outstanding competitors
through three rounds of competition
but
there can only be one
forged and fire champion
jay
oh pete
that damascus blade was beautiful i mean
getting all those wells folded together
grinding that all evenly heat treating
it the way you did it stood up to all
the tests you did a wonderful job on
that piece of steel
i had a couple of issues with the way
your handle was put together with that
spacer the
spacer really started chewing into my
hand
i just couldn't get a good grip up
around the top of this sword that's an
issue
comments for dave well dave even though
the overall look of your sword and the
design of your handle was very appealing
obviously it was a heat treatment issue
during the tests your blade folded over
and that really [ __ ] in the testing
dave i love the design of your blade
very clean lines your handle felt very
good in the hand it's sharp it thrusts
well but in the end it failed when we
started slicing the bones
pete
you are the forged and fire champion
congratulations
dave your sword felt great in the hand
but when i used it on those bones boy it
just bent right over the top and a heat
treat issue like that
we just can't let that through
dave you did an outstanding job
please surrender your weapon
the judge's decision was what it was and
if i can't change it then why worry
about it
i had a tremendous time doing this it
was an education a wonderful experience
and definitely one that i'm never gonna
forget
pete congratulations you're receiving a
check for ten thousand dollars that's
pretty nice how do you feel i i feel
great i feel really good i think my wife
when we get to hawaii
we're gonna lie back and relax she's had
to put up with me being gone for this
she deserves it
[Music]
you